Gentlemen, my favorite
activities are camping,
pool parties, and picnics,
but you can't have any of those
things without a barbecue.
In this first round
of competition,
you'll have to harvest steel
from this barbecue
and forge camp knives
between ten
and 12 inches in length
as measured from the tip
to the plunge grind.
And one other thing.
Your blades must also include...
an operational bottle opener.
Good luck, Bladesmiths.
Your time starts...
now.
Immediately, I look at the spit
and that looks to me
like it's gonna
be high-carbon steel.
Put it down. Put it down
a little lower past this.
Now it's up to their own
skill set to determine
what's mild steel,
what's high-carbon steel,
and how to assemble those
things into a billet.
Well, let's test some
of these pieces of steel here.
You can do a spark test.
But a surefire way
is take a piece of steel,
get it hot, quench it,
and check it.
[Cameron] I chop off
a little piece of that spit,
I throw it in
the forge immediately
to see if I can get it
up to temp, quench it,
and check to see if it's hard.
As that piece gets up to heat,
I quench it...
[dramatic rock music playing]
No.
The file does not skate at all,
which means that that's not
hardenable steel.
I need to think of a plan B.
Ding. Light bulb goes off.
Throw it in a canister.
I'm just gonna cut up
pieces of steel
and I'm gonna throw all of it
into a canister with 1095,
and that will hopefully
give me a solid billet.
If you're not sure
what's in there,
I'd go with canister Damascus.
You got a 1095 carbon steel
you know you can mix
in between.
Once my billet is up
to the right temperature,
I'm gonna
very gently squeeze it.
Just think of it
as like a snowball.
You push too hard,
it's gonna go everywhere.
You slowly pack it both ways,
and after you get
to where you need to be,
you can get some force on.
First you need
to take baby steps
to get that weld set.
It's now or never.
I gotta get this welded.
Oh no.
Oh, come on, man.
What happened to the canister?
[Justin] Big old gap in there.
This is bad.
[bleep]!
[Cameron]
As I peel off the canister,
I am just hoping
that I have a solid weld.
Oh no.
-[Wil] Oh!
-What? What?
Wow. I dropped it
when I was grinding,
and it split on me.
He's inspecting
the inner contents,
to see if they welded up,
and he doesn't look happy.
[David] Again, when
he came off the press,
it didn't look like
he'd reduced that can much.
He might not have
pressed it down.
[Cameron]
This is unusable steel.
[Ben] Check out Justin.
I think he's thinking about
what to do now.
I have to start over.
Now I'm moving on
to that big chunk of spit.
Just taking the best guess
on what I know
I can at least get
a nice-shaped object out of.
I cut off pieces of the grate.
All right, round two.
Here we go.
I know that
I'm up against the clock,
and it's gonna be tight, it's
gonna come down to the wire,
but I never give up.
[dramatic rock music playing]
We got Nick trying to bang
a billet out of a hot can.
It's not working out for him.
[Nick] It is very difficult.
Luckily, the can
finally comes off.
-Woo.
-There we go.
[Justin] I've never put a bottle
opener in a blade before.
I'm gonna put a ring
at the back end of the knife.
I think that swell will help
keep the knife in your hand,
and it's not up on the blade
in case you have to baton it,
and you're not
gonna cut yourself
when you're opening your beer
when you're camping or fishing.
[Wil] Justin was
able to quickly forge out
a blade with his mono steel
and Cameron's still working
on his second can.
[Doug] He's still got
a long ways to go.
We gotta heat treat this thing.
Nick's blade is looking nice.
That's a nice camp knife shape.
My blade is fully hardened.
Justin just quenched.
[Justin] I'm just praying
to the gods of metal
that this blade
is gonna come out hard.
It's not hard.
I think, "Well, maybe
I'm working with mild steel."
If I don't have a hard blade,
I might get eliminated.
I'm freaking out.
I don't have time to make
a whole 'nother blade.
All I need to do is have
a high-carbon edge.
I'm gonna cut
some pieces off this grate,
and I'm gonna do a snap test.
I know if I hit that
son of a bitch
with a hammer
and it breaks,
that means it has carbon
in it and it got hard
and I can forge weld
it onto the edge.
-Broke it right off.
[Wil] Now you know
that's hardened steel.
[Cameron] I'm able to peel
my second canister off
and start forging it.
[Wil] Cameron is so far behind
the power curve.
[Cameron] I know that
to meet the parameters,
I still have to put the bottle
opener on this knife.
[Wil] Cameron needs
to work very quickly
because he still
has to quench that blade.
Justin is perfectly shaping
that piece of high-carbon steel
to the edge of his blade.
I really do applaud the fact
that he was
in the middle of that
and found a way out.
I like it.
[Justin] The clock's ticking.
I'm almost out of time.
The high-carbon steel on
my edge needs to get hard.
[dramatic music playing]
And here comes the file test.
[bleep] yeah, man. It's hard.
Thirty seconds!
You got enough.
You got enough, buddy.
-Thank you!
-There you go!
[Ben] You got it.
Five, four, three,
two, one!
This first round
of competition is over.
All right, Bladesmiths.
This is the sharpness test,
the pork shoulder slice.
Unlike the strength test,
this is all about
what your edge will do
to these pork shoulders.
Cameron, you're up first.
Are you ready?
Yes, please.
[dramatic music playing]
Since we asked you
to do a bottle opener,
we're gonna test if it'll open.
Just to let you know,
it's root beer,
because we don't beer and blade.
[chuckling]
[dramatic music playing]
All right, Cameron, first up.
Your bottle opener works.
Your edge, it's not
very sharp, but it cuts.
But that's a lot also to do
with the velocity I'm doing
in chopping through
the meat right there.
With everything
that you've done,
your blade, sir, it'll cut.
Justin, it's your turn.
-Are you ready, sir?
-Oh yeah, bud.
[dramatic music playing]
Geez.
All right, Justin.
Your edge not only is sharp,
but look at what it did.
It cut through bone.
It's a deep cutter.
And of course...
I got a swig.
Overall, sir, your blade,
it will cut.
Thank you.
Nick, your turn, sir.
Are you ready?
-Let's do it.
-Let's do this.
[dramatic rock music playing]
I'm thirsty!
And... ah!
I guess I'm gonna
do this test thirsty.
-Nice.
-Thanks.
All right, Nick.
It's very nice,
it slice and dice.
Nice slashes, nice deep cuts.
Even cuts to the bone.
But I'm still thirsty.
Overall, sir, your blade,
it will cut.
Yes.
All right, gents, it's time
for one of you Bladesmiths
to leave the Forge.
The Bladesmith
leaving the Forge is...
Cameron.
Your blade did not make the cut.
You did a great job,
but at this time,
I need you to please
surrender your blade.
[Cameron] I'm proud
that I never really gave up.
-Good job, Cam. Seriously.
-Thanks.
I believe that I gave
everything I had
through this entire challenge,
and I sure had
a hell of a time competing.